JEFFREY POSNICK:
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to this week's YouTube
Developers Live.
I'm Jeff Posnick coming to
you all from New York.
And this week we have some
special guests, the folks
behind Magisto.
And that would be Oren Boiman,
who's the CEO and founder; and
Ori Hasse, the VP of Research
and Development.
So, welcome, guys.
Thanks so much for joining us.
OREN BOIMAN: Thank you.
Thank you for inviting us.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
I'm really excited
about this show.
I'm flying solo this week.
My colleagues Jeremy and Jarek
are both traveling, and you
guys will have to put
up with me for now.
Before we get started,
not everybody's
familiar with Magisto.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your company?
When was Magisto founded?
Where are you guys based?
And we'll talk more about
product in a bit.
OREN BOIMAN: Sure.
Magisto is kind of a magical
video editor.
It's an app that takes any kind
of plain, ordinary videos
and edits them automatically,
like a human video editor
expert would do.
But it does that in any scale
and essentially in real time.
And so it takes the real boring
videos that everyone
knows and do nothing with and
turns it to unforgettable
movies that you want to
share with everyone.
And it does it in a
matter of minutes.
This seemingly simple task of
editing videos is actually a
very, very complicated task
involving a lot of artificial
intelligence technology that is
about understanding what's
going on inside the video and
then deciding how to tell a
story out of the footage that
you have, and then doing,
obviously, all the technical
stuff of delivering the video
and providing it to the user.
We founded the company in 2009,
basically just starting
with very strong technologies
for video understanding, which
is the domain of, I'd say,
artificial intelligence in
this video.
And we've built Magisto as a
consumer product around it to
enable essentially everyone
to be able to do something
meaningful with the videos that
we all capture but do
nothing with.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Awesome.
And you guys, I know, are coming
to us live from Tel
Aviv right now.
So thanks for staying up late
and joining us with the time
zone difference.
And you talked a little bit
about what Magisto is.
Who are the target users
for Magisto?
What type of people go out
and find it useful?
OREN BOIMAN: There's actually
a very wide range of users.
It's basically everyone
that captures video.
Because essentially
the raw footage
that everyone captures--
it might be on smartphones,
camcorders,
digital still camera--
it is something that holds
the most important
memories that you have.
But actually, no one does
something meaningful with most
of the personal video.
If you think, for instance, on
YouTube, most of the content
that's being uploaded to YouTube
doesn't contain all
the videos that people
capture.
It is only the best
of the best of the
video that people capture.
And the reason is that video
requires editing, but
editing is a task.
Manual video editing is
something which is very
complicated.
It can take someone who is not
very proficient with this task
between hours to days
to get to a few
good minutes of video.
But without the--
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes,
I definitely have
experience with that.
Yes, indeed.
OREN BOIMAN: Yeah.
Many, many people consider video
editing as a one-time
experience.
You do it only once because
you're so discouraged by that.
Videos, for everyone, contain
a lot of the most important
experiences that we have, but
we have nothing to do with
them, because it's
too difficult.
So essentially, it's everyone.
But if you go deeper to
understand who are the
consumers of such a product, you
can find, again, teenagers
using Magisto to create fun
experiences they've had with
their friends, young parents
trying to document their
children's lives and sharing
them with the family, people
doing amazing things
on YouTube.
We have an integration in
YouTube, which we can discuss.
People are uploading very
interesting public content.
It might be just a sports event,
and they create very
interesting highlights of that
with music and everything.
So, essentially, everyone that
wants to communicate using
video will find very high value
in Magisto, because it
takes out the work of
video editing and
just keeps the fun.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
And I personally have a young
son at home, and I've used
Magisto a couple of times now
to take the 10 minutes of
footage that you shoot waiting
for something interesting
happen and kind of condense
that down into something a
little bit more manageable.
And it really works well.
We've been talking about it,
and your product, it really
hits home more when you see
a video demo of it.
So we have a recorded video
that I wanted to show
everybody now so you can get
a better feel for what the
product is.
It specifically talks
about the Android
integration that you have.
OREN BOIMAN: Awesome.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool video.
So hopefully, folks know a bit
more about what we're talking
about right now and have the
visual to connect to it.
Yeah, so if you wanted to say
a bit more about what the
integration is like with this
Android application--
I don't know if you want to do
that demo that we were trying
before, where you would show
from Android, or if you want
to do a screen share to give
people more of a live feel for
the product, whatever would be
the best way for you to show
things off.
OREN BOIMAN: So maybe I'll do
a screen share to show--
first, before discussing
the Android
integration, I'll show--
actually, the first integration
that we did is
inside YouTube Create.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That would be
perfect, given that this is
the YouTube show.
We probably shouldn't talk too
much about the Android stuff.
We'll focus on the YouTube
integration.
OREN BOIMAN: So what you see
right now on the screen is
Magisto on YouTube Create.
That's
youtube.com/create/magisto.
And if you want to use Magisto
on YouTube just to send
directly videos to YouTube, you
can go straight to there.
And you get a very similar flow
or user interface to use
Magisto inside YouTube.
So you can either upload your
files from your computer, or
you can use the very recent
Google Drive Inspiration--
JEFFREY POSNICK: Which
I love, by the way.
I was trying that because I have
all my home movies backed
up on Google Drive already.
So not having to re-upload
them really was amazing.
OREN BOIMAN: Right.
And it is extremely fast.
That's the good thing.
So let's do a live demo here,
where I'll select some files
from my Google Drive
and use them.
These are full HD videos that
would take me a lot of time to
upload from my laptop.
And here I select a couple of
videos, and I will just add
them to the movie I want
to create with Magisto.
And after you select the videos
themselves, then you
can add a title to the
movie if you want.
So let's call that--
[TYPING].
And then you can select
some soundtrack.
Let's select some party
beat style.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sounds good.
OREN BOIMAN: That's good.
And going to try this one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OREN BOIMAN: Awesome.
This is it.
What happened right now is that
YouTube managed to upload
more than I think 150 megabytes
in the split of a
second, because it was done
from Google Drive.
And right now, Magisto engine
servers are doing the number
crunching to analyze the video,
produce it, do the
editing and everything.
In a couple of minutes, it's
going to be ready.
And it's going to be ready
on My Movies in Magisto.
It's going to be posted
to your YouTube.
It's going to be available
on my Android
device, if I have one.
It's all connected to the
same account, which is
stored on the cloud.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Gotcha.
And just for folks that are
seeing that use flow for the
first time, when I was going
through it, it's kind of hard
for somebody who's used to the
traditional video-editing
experience where you have to
think very carefully about,
these are the clips I want to
splice together in this
particular order.
It's like handing off control
and trusting the algorithm a
bit to get things right, which
obviously makes things
wonderful for people who really
don't want to face the
task of doing their
own video editing.
How much can you tell us about
what's going on behind the
scenes in terms of your back-end
algorithms for
actually finding the interesting
portions of the
video or the most relevant
portion?
Obviously, I don't want you
to disclose anything too
proprietary.
But I'm curious, and I'm sure a
lot of other folks are, too.
OREN BOIMAN: What I can say is
there's two parts to the basic
engine that we do in order to
analyze and produce video.
We started from videos
and pixels.
And in order to do this in video
editing, you need to
move from notions such as pixels
to very high-level
notions, such as characters and
scenes and behaviors and
interactions between
people and objects.
And there might be
pets, whatever.
So the first step that we do
is a step of analysis that,
using the very sophisticated
technology we have to look for
video understanding, leaves
us with kind of--
it is a semantic description of
what's going on essentially
in every frame in the video.
But it's not low-level
description, such as things
are moving, but this
is an object.
This is an important
character.
He moves from left to right.
The camera's tracking him.
It's doing zoom in, et
cetera, et cetera.
And we manage to use this
metadata in order to decide
what are the important parts of
the video, where we should
focus, how to tell the story,
what parts can we discard from
the editing.
So the second part of the
algorithm we apply is less
analytical and more--
you can think of
it as an expert
system of a video editor.
So this is the creative
part, right?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Which is
historically very difficult to
codify in an algorithm.
OREN BOIMAN: And that is a
different domain, right?
Even with accurate description
of everything that goes on the
video, you still have to decide
how to tell a story.
That's art.
That's art and algorithms.
And then you need to decide
what's the basic information
that we have in the video?
The video footage that the user
provided obviously didn't
help a lot.
It doesn't tag the videos.
It's just raw footage.
So we need to decide
it automatically.
And then what we also do is we
take the user selection, for
instance, the user's selection
of music and theme, and we use
the selection in order to decide
how to tell the story.
So, for instance, you can take
basic footage of essentially
everything and tell it like a
horror story, or tell it like
a comedy, or tell
it like it's a
nostalgic, sentimental story.
And that's editing.
Editing is manipulation of the
footage, and it can tell a
story many ways.
So we take the selection of
the user of the theme, and
then we select how to inject
the right emotion.
So you could take the same
footage with Magisto and try
to edit one time with party rock
and the next time with
some old-style jazz music.
It's going to look completely
different.
It's not going to only
sound different.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That's
really interesting.
I didn't realize that--
OREN BOIMAN: You can
probably do--
JEFFREY POSNIAK: --from
the YouTube--
OREN BOIMAN: --different
selections.
Different selections and
completely different editing,
and that's part of the fun.
I mean, if you want to
inject some emotion,
we'll let you do that.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK.
Yeah, I struggled for a while
to find the right musical
track to go with video
footage of my son.
I didn't actually realize that
the musical track I chose
would also affect the
editing decisions.
So that's definitely
an interesting
thing to keep in mind.
OREN BOIMAN: And the last part
is obviously that this entire
engine is wrapped in very, very
sophisticated back end
and front end that
need to scale.
Because this is the kind of--
by the way, the video that
we just rated is ready.
I just got a notification,
video is ready.
You can take it from your
iPhone, Android device, or
just go to the web and watch
the video, or YouTube,
depending on when you put it.
So again, the back end here is
extremely sophisticated.
And the standard needs to scale
tasks which are very,
very heavy.
Video editing is very different
from handling things
such as messaging or tweeting
or stuff like that.
When it happens, the load
of the system increases
dramatically.
And you need to be able to scale
with huge amounts of
video that might happen, like
hundreds of thousands of
videos per day.
Also, in that case, the
algorithms are very
specifically designed
to this kind of
management of the task.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Gotcha.
That's super interesting.
Thank you for opening up like
that about a little bit of
what's going on with
your secret
sauce behind the product.
Given that, I kind of wanted
to shift the focus a little
bit to talk about the specific
YouTube integration and some
of the technical
details there.
This is, after all, a YouTube
Developers Live show.
And just maybe start with a
general question about which
of the YouTube APIs
are you using--
data API, player API,
that sort of thing.
ORI HASSE: We're using
actually a
lot of YouTube APIs.
We're using YouTube APIs for
user authentication and
connecting to the service.
We, of course, use
the YouTube.
We use the Google APIs for
connecting to the service.
We use YouTube data APIs to
upload videos to YouTube, also
parsed it with specific
metadata that
we add to the videos.
We use also Google G+ and
GDrive APIs to connect
everything together.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And I just
wanted to point out, thank you
very much for using OAuth 2,
I noticed, as part of your
authorization flow.
Because that presented a really
nice authorization
experience to me as a user.
And it's something that we
always try to hammer home to
developers out there, that
OAuth 2 is the way to go.
ORI HASSE: Yeah, and it also
will work very nicely on the
Android to allow you to have
a seamless experience.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah,
absolutely.
So you're using a wide
range of data APIs.
In terms of the actual
underlying languages that a
lot of your code base is written
in for interacting
with YouTube, what's most of
your code that handles talking
to the APIs written in?
Which language?
ORI HASSE: This part of the
system, our code is in Python.
JEFFREY POSNICK: OK, cool.
Are you using the Python Client
Library to talk to
YouTube, or did you end up
rolling your own interface?
ORI HASSE: No.
Currently, we use a bit older
GData client library.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Which,
apologies in
advance about that.
ORI HASSE: Yeah, and we're
moving now to the new APIs.
JEFFREY POSNICK: The Python
Client Library, in particular,
for GData is rather
out of date.
And we've been telling people,
wait, wait, wait.
We're going to have something
better coming out.
So we do finally now have the
new Version 3 out there, and a
nice new Python Client Library
to talk to Version 3.
It's obviously a big
undertaking.
I assume you guys haven't had
a chance to migrate yet, but
hopefully you've checked
out the new client
library for Version 3.
ORI HASSE: Yeah, we didn't
migrate the YouTube APIs yet,
but we're going to do
it pretty soon.
JEFFREY POSNICK: And since
you're already using a lot of
other Google APIs, hopefully
you'll have the advantage of
having one client library that
you could use to talk to
Google+, or Drive, or any
other of the Google APIs
you're integrating with.
OK, so, any general feedback you
have for me as a developer
who's built a pretty
tight integration?
This is your chance to let us
know what we could be doing
better with the API and any
questions that you might have.
OREN BOIMAN: So first, one thing
that I think might be
interesting to people doing
the show is that we have
released recently an API to
Magisto that we think it might
be very interesting to YouTube
developers to sync with video.
We have now Magisto capabilities
as developers and
very interesting stuff that
we don't do with the
product right now.
For instance, we've seen advance
from real estate
agencies that capture a lot of
video footage, but they don't
get it to a very high-quality
form, but they can use the
Magisto API in order to make it
perfect and then stream it
to YouTube.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
That's amazing.
Cool.
OREN BOIMAN: We'll amazing
things with legacy content,
which is premium, but you want
to create trailers and do it
in mass scale.
So the only way to do mass-scale
video editing right
now is the Magisto API.
So I think that that's going
to be very interesting to
YouTube developers.
Just go to
developers.magisto.com and get
an API key and start
to work with it.
I think it's going to be--
it's surprising how many
applications we have not
thought about that can
be done with video
editing and video footage.
So that's one thing--
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
I'll make sure some
folks internally
know about that, too.
Because I know you mentioned the
real estate videos, and I
know that's a pretty
common thing.
They're trying to sell something
using YouTube, and
they tend to be like a minute
of the same shots over and
over again.
So that's very interesting.
OREN BOIMAN: And I think that
as developers of the YouTube
API, I think that what we've
seen, for instance, on the
YouTube Create channel, is that
people create a lot of
interesting content from meshing
and remixing content.
It might be premium content and
their personal content.
I'm not sure if all the
content is captured
in the right way.
But I think that this is the
kind of thing that YouTube can
provide, especially with the
Magisto as an app on it,
amazing opportunities for people
to be creative, to take
new kinds of content,
and re-mesh them.
And we've seen amazing things
such as taking some trailer of
a movie, and then taking it
through Magisto, creating a
hard-rock, one-minute version,
and putting it again to
YouTube, getting amazing
traction and responses because
it's something completely
different and creative.
So I think the opportunities
here are huge.
We're just waiting to get a hold
of these kinds of APIs
and provide users with these
kinds of options.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That definitely
makes sense.
I think that's feedback I've
heard before from other
developers and probably
from you as well.
So it's certainly something
that we know about and are
trying to find the best
solution for.
Very, very appreciated
feedback, that.
Anything else that we haven't
covered yet that you feel we
left out an important feature
of showing off with Magisto?
Any other feedback that you
might have beyond that?
OREN BOIMAN: So I think that,
again, just to mention again
that beyond the API and Magisto
on YouTube, we have
the integration right now
on iOS and Android.
I think that right now, most of
the videos that the people
capture are on smartphones, so
definitely people just want to
experience--
the best way to experience
Magisto, start from the
smartphones and then
go to the APIs.
Go to magisto.com.
We're very interested to hear
about people's opinions on how
to use it and how to better use
inside YouTube as well.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cool.
That definitely makes sense.
I've checked it out.
It's a great product, so
hopefully, other folks will go
out and try it as well.
I apologize for some of the
background noise here.
It kind of feels like we're in
a bank vault and somebody's
trying to break in
to the studio.
So before anything drastic
happens, it might be
time to sign off.
Before I do, I wanted to give a
quick plug to the fact that
YouTube Developer Relations and
Google Developer Relations
in general is hiring, as
we tend to be doing.
Developers.google.com/jobs is
the place to go if you're
interested, you're out there
watching this and you're
interested in doing the sort
of thing that I do.
And we really wanted to
thank Oren and Ori
for joining us tonight.
Things are getting a little loud
here, so it might be time
to go while we still can.
So thanks so much.
OREN BOIMAN: Bye-bye.
ORI HASSE: Bye-bye.
OREN BOIMAN: Thank you.
ORI HASSE: Thank you so much.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Cheers.